[Music]
[Applause]
merry christmas
gamers and welcome to a special
christmas episode
marta is going to join me in animal
crossing
damn i'm getting good at the flute she
better have a flute it was i
was about to say i have not played in so
long but now there's christmas
yeah look at this
what is this it's missing a piece in the
ground must fix immediately
oh i'm making it worse so this is how
parents feel like when they play games
i understand so i finally got it working
i have my uh switch from the uh dbrand
so cool right and i can't even show them
either way i can actually record animal
crossing finally thanks because before
whatever it's a long story oh look at
that we got christmas tree
anyway this is my island here is my
little stage area if you want to perform
oh i don't have a flute it's pretty nice
you have your friends over
two people can watch epic i'm just gonna
do a quick tour
no one cares about my island we're gonna
go over to martinez in a sec
i am proud of my tulip tulipins is that
what it's called i don't know
got my gas station i really want it to
be like a
an urban cozy feel slash japanese style
you know
it's cool the amount of time and effort
i spend into this it's just ridiculous
i don't know where how do i begin how do
i begin to get back into this
but i never showed it simple park here
yeah
it's epic we got the lights we got the
we got the stuff
does it bother people that i have
branches i'll pick it up
uh and then over here in the east we
have the neighborhoods
everyone have their little house neatly
organized
which again i was very oh can you catch
these
you can catch these right oh sweet
i got the tsuki merch oh no my my net
all right whatever all the neighborhoods
i don't know i feel like this isn't
impressive anymore everyone does this
but at the time it was cool right
i even had my stone farm i haven't been
here in a while uh
ignore ignore it's been a while guys my
little outdoor work area
and this is cool right so ignore all the
flowers i'm just breeding stuff
oh hold up
oh i'm good at this thank you
okay all the fruits all the different
trees bam
bam ignore the flowers bam
bam bam yeah
i'll probably organize all the flowers
at some point
i'll definitely do that but i was just
breeding i was trying to get golden
tulips it didn't work
i did something wrong but i have a bunch
of different ones
roses i mean of course this is where the
bears chill
yeah they enjoy it thanks for asking
listen i spent a lot of time on this
watch it okay here's my theme park i'm
still breeding these that's why they're
all over the place
godzilla's of course it's a nice little
playground i like it you can talk to
turtle
if you want he's cool is it a turtle i
don't know
i kiss him we got the video games we got
the darts
we got the beautiful scenery of the
ocean it's got the water theme
it's whatever it's the greatest park of
all time do you know how much time i
spent on this
say that it's nice thank you thank you
because there's you know there's a
symmetry but there's always an asymmetry
and there's a fine
balance in today that a lot of people
don't appreciate the nuances of
yeah yeah i don't really have much here
i don't know why that's there
more flower breeding oh ignore ignore
flower for breeding a nice little
kissing spot maybe i'll bring my tea
here later
there used to be two waterfalls to make
it epic but
it was too intrusive you don't want to
overdo it in animal crossing you know
oh look there's christmas tree they got
lights in them
i'm definitely gonna get back oh long
boy you've been here so long
he's longing for the ocean he can't wait
i love my island i think it's cool now
if we head over to the west of the
island we have more flower breeding
i spent so much time and now i i did
nothing with it
it hurts oh gosh
what's happening what is that whoa
what is this oh my god it's a ball
i'm making a ball i'm making a snowball
is this how you do it
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what
is this
we're making a meatball oh there's
another ball
do i merge the balls
how does this work no
more flower breeding i am so mad at
myself for not doing anything with that
hey guess what guys more flower breeding
so this is my camp area i was going to
organize all the flowers because
you know it matches background and
here's a little cinema wall where you
can watch look there's a projector back
there
it's cozy say it's cozy and nice thank
you
yeah you can just camp out welcome to uh
i named this island wakanda
i'm really glad i did that definitely
and then we have what everyone did
apparently now
i swear this is the most basic at
this point but here's my viewing point
so you got cars there in the distance
you got mountains
here we have our holy gnome where you
have to sacrifice
uh three of your dreams to pass okay
all done thank you gnome little spa very
nice
and then i think this is the last thing
i was working on a little marketplace
which is kind of sad because i'm the
only one here
anyways let's head over to march yet see
what she's doing
oh yeah this is the back entrance to the
to the viewing point
it's pretty cool it's whatever spend a
million hours on it
it's cool it's whatever don't really
care
but yeah that's my island let's go visit
marx yeah because that's why everyone
here mad what's that why
i can't hear you can you write me on
whatsapp
my channel has been working hard on this
say that it's nice
okay say a single hate comment
you're banned for life
we go whoa that's like a whole city
i want this i am
[Music]
oh it's snowing cute
whoa there she is
cute how do i emote
oh sorry wrong merry christmas everyone
[Music]
what is she doing all the little doggies
are these gifts for me i'm gonna guess
oh i get christmas gifts
what are they oops
it's a rain yeah
where's the other one oh
no call me
[Laughter]
all right time for tour
uh we got the beach what a cute little
pen and look you can sit here
this is nice christmas at the beef some
stuff hasn't changed
well it doesn't have to if it looks good
hey what are you doing with that shovel
oh it's like she was attacking me
oh what have we got i remember that this
is how the tambo stuff started
oh i get a balloon
amazing oh how cute
let's watch out for her actual demon
creations oh god i'm easily entertained
don't judge me where did she go listen i
gave her a lot of these flowers
so i deserve some credit
what all right cute little garden house
very nice i see what you did there
that's smart greenhouse that's what it's
called thank you
very cozy you got some weeds here is
that
that's intentional it's a static this is
my favorite emoji in case you haven't
noticed
oh sorry am i too slow
okay cute seashells hey
hey oh
she looks like she's about to murder me
what did she do
i'm here
what what was that
hey this is cool whoa
whoa there's octopussies that's so cool
i don't even know they ah that's dope
so you got these flowers on your own
these purple ones
[Laughter]
cute very cute
i'm giving it christmas spirit it's
gonna taste better trust me
just okay i'm done oh
snow boy wait what's that
yo glory mushroom i want this oh my god
what is this painting
you wouldn't know oh okay maybe i would
oh delicious
what is this called like a chinese
buffet table or something
what's a chinese restaurant that's so
cute
[Music]
oh what's happening oh
i guess i guess i'll still look like
this
[Music]
nice
ah this has been improved that's cool
it's like we're in japan where we were
supposed to be
oh nice
oh there's a spot for me too to sit next
to you in the park that's so cute
[Music]
wow cool hey gutilazan
still there nice ouch
what happened this is marching being
marcia she falls all the time
yo oh she's all right
oh we can finally sit together here we
[Music]
go
see i know oh there we go
very nice little mini
camping section i like it whoa
you got venus beautiful did you draw
this
of course
thank you i appreciate it beautiful
capture my beauty
nice nice
what a christmas mood everyone hope
you're having a great christmas
oh they got the missile thingy oh we got
a snow version too
cute let's get them synced
perfect
[Music]
oh you go no i had it
all right watch out for bears got it i
remember this
whoa you got the golden rose how
how i'm bro yeah well we know that
[Laughter]
oh we got maya
look down whoa
cozy i like that wasn't there a haunted
mansion before
where'd she go oh there's snowman where
did she go
yes i know exactly where that is
comment
[Music]
all right let's see the inside does it
match the outside
oh cozy i like it oh this is awesome
which room are you in
oh there you are you missed me
yeah the bedroom doesn't look like a
massage room
oh yeah i'm missing i remember
i'll be the judge of that oh you're
right that's cozier
i like it very nice bedroom
she left okay oh there's lots to see
gotcha i'm a little sad i don't have my
candle but you know what
at least this time i have it in real
life
this is great cozy bathroom
some things never well not if they're
good
oh no no no i know no
no help help me
stop it stop it change
things back oh the toilet move there's
ghosts
ah stop
oh god that she was referring to the
furniture
it's like it never happened
this is your crafting area oh
oh we got the puffer fish a little
puffer
martial loves pugs puffer fishes and
then somewhere at the bottom is me
oh looks similar oh thanks
[Laughter]
is this where all the devilish creations
are made
yeah i did yeah
[Music]
nice are we going upstairs okay
downstairs
how is she so fast i'm supposed to be
the gamer
hey you got mr turtle too
[Music]
this
no it's been confirmed
oh i see it this is a crafting cute
nice i feel like she yeah she would make
it like this in real life
okay so now let's burn it
hey okay let's go
whoa whoa that's so cool
that's so cozy i like that this is my
favorite room
whoa it feels like you're upstairs too
that's cool i like it
yo you got a dollar house what i didn't
know they had that
these are like swedish um i don't know
what it is
oh what did i just do
[Music]
hey dance with me
oh
[Laughter]
knives powers what are you cooking
pasta or pizza
[Music]
she's actually making pasta
fine you know what fine oh you got ping
pong
so fun absolutely amazing so interactive
i should play vr ping pong with my dad
and my mom the other day it was so funny
is this your snowman very nice very
stylish
yeah oh they're so cute
oh you got a little gaming area i like
that hey
i gave you these i gave you these
say it say it
are you serious all right cute little
camping
a little are you making pizza
nice cool oh we got different treats
cute cute oh you can roast marshmallows
hey if i roll an apple you have to make
me pasta
do i have to press
thank you thank you
so nothing changes full viewing area
nice
oh wow for you all
oh okay the sash on this girl
oh a cute christmas tree i didn't
realize hey
lights turn on oh nice that's okay
oh yeah this uh kanji means tomate i
know that now which means stop
look at that i'm sony hungo
i think you missed that oh you missed it
again
[Music]
yeah damn there's so much to see i don't
know how to get this stuff
oh i can open the oh it's a volcano no
it isn't your camping ground it just
looks like it oh cool i
told me where's she going hello
oh she got one of these uh beef thing
do you think she's making pasta
she's cute okay
and she even made a little sand castle
very cozy
yeah oh it's a bus station you're improv
day nice
wait stop it
cozy hey why is there a melon
get rid of it no
oh it's a oh oh yeah
let's kill it coco mill in bed a panda
on
whoa what
bro what is this whoa
what i never seen this
oh all right bye
oh yeah there was a bunch of stars and
stuff i never got these
that's cool
we go to school but it's christmas
holiday
i remember you showed me this this is
cool got a classroom
nice very nice
oh let's see
[Music]
what oh it's like a classroom or
kindergarten
and cake amazing
is that stone she put stone in her bent
though
oh she's got acquired taste oh it's cl
uh
fair ah
nice that's cool that's smart
this is me in school basically
[Music]
i like his shirt that's fire dude
hell yeah you don't are you okay bro
is she treating you well you can talk to
me
just blink just blink if oh
[Music]
okay
i lost you there you are oh god put down
the shovel
oh it's a clay a pottery classist every
sunday
can i sign up nice
i didn't realize you can decorate other
people's houses
oh cool damn what
no way whoa i like that
she looks like a waiter or a chef oh
it's a hint
sorry croco all right what's next
we'll see bear
hey we're matching
yeah oh look at this
[Music]
secret t-spot all right
yeah i love how you did the city that's
so cool i saw it on the plane
oh sit ah
how do you even do that oh i see how
that's cool
cool nice
yeah oh little doggy
we've been here oh god who's that what
what are you ugh
no thank you
matrix what that's so awesome
ah we're in the spoopy area oh god what
did you do marzian
this is where the real demons are spawn
from
the furbys mass produce headquarters
oh god oh no right there going inside
i'm going in oh god no
oh
god this is actually spooky
oh god
amnesia all over again you can't do it
oh my god
we play so well
this is creepy you look so crazy
[Laughter]
this is too evil
help me
going to sleep
[Music]
how do you get this creepy soundtrack
no no
go back to sleep i wake up from this
nightmare
no no
the true horrors oh god
let's get out of here no there's more
ah what happened
oh i see oh god let's not wait
wake the demon
[Music]
what are you doing oh
she was like father to me all right
i'm placing all my animal crossing coins
on red
[Music]
what do i win oh
great hey i got balloon back
yep i like this area more
nice
[Music]
thank you for the tour i'll write it
four out of five
i mean five five of course 10 out of 10.
okay it's my time to go
five out of five five out of five
i was joking come on what is this whoa
[Music]
nice amazing wow
happy holidays everyone and happy new
years
five now five out of yeah now it's five
out of five you're right
by luna greece amazing
hey stop it
yeah thank you all right
on that now that was the animal crossing
christmas special thank you marcie for
showing your island
bon
[Music]
what is that oh i see
okay
on that note thank you for watching this
year it's been incredible
i really appreciate all the subscribers
look at the graph one last time
and i see you guys have an amazing
christmas